alors quoi de beau bonjour à toutes et à
tous quoi de beau ce week-end j'espère
que je vous ai pas trop manqué
apparemment même si on passe à l'heure
d'été on y est toujours pas les
températures nous le monde de toute
façon il y a plus de saison et puis si
vous voulez plus d'informations
n'hésitez pas c'est marqué juste à côté
moi je prends les retours j'ai vu qu'il
y en avait pas beaucoup sur le dernier
épisode donc on hésite vraiment pas
moi sinon je m'ennuie derrière s'il y a
des réclamations l'adresse email existe
toujours sachez que j'en ai pas
tellement au sud donc je pense que je
suis parfait dans la présentation merci
à tous des plus épars sont à attendre
tout le week-end est-ce que vous
connaissez la différence entre puisé
pars et rares averses c'est la vraie
question qu'on se pose tout en attendant
que les cartes des fils bien sûr c'est
mon job alors la différence est toute
simple des rares averses ça peut arriver
n'importe quand soudainement et repartir
comme c'est venu alors que des pluies
épars c'est ce qui est vraiment chiant
ça arrive tout le temps et puis pas
vraiment donc voilà on est c'est plus du
long terme les plus épars
voilà et alors j'ai cherché plein de
synonymes pour plus épars parce que il y
a ça tout le week-end donc je vais vous
les faire un par un tout en attendant
que les cartes des fils bien sûr ce
week-end il faut attendre des plus épars
c'est weekend il faut attendre
depuis disperser depuis 10 minutes au
début c'est parti depuis Spotify depuis
longtemps le problème c'est que j'ai
commencé avec ma main gauche là j'ai pas
bouger ma main et puis continue et mon
préféré ce weekend il faut attendre des
pluies constellés nous allons maintenant
voir les Yvelinois vous toujours vous il
y a que vous de toute façon on va parler
du premier avril qui est samedi on va
voir ce que vous avez préparé c'est
parti
ouais c'est des questions vraiment
essentielles là est-ce que vous
connaissez l'origine du poisson d'avril
monsieur
du tout non pas trop non non pas du tout
sur mon import je suppose puisque elle
est un poisson
je suppose vous voulez quelle couleur
chef j'ai plein de petits poissons pas
raciste
on est professionnel
j'ai pas le premier ah oui si mais non
c'est dommage vendredi non c'est samedi
mais là on est on est samedi monsieur là
vous avez une blague à nous partager
peut-être
j'en ai une de Jacques Dutronc j'ai eu
hier il lui demandait
qu'est-ce qu'il voulait faire il a dit
j'ai toujours fait tous les jours j'ai
tiré la chasse après
[Rires]
l'histoire des deux nanas qui
m'attendent à poil
moi non plus c'est dommage d'histoire
commence bien moi j'en ai une elle est
vraiment hard qu'est-ce qui est jaune et
qui court vite alors là je sais pas LA
MERDE Si trop pressé
vous allez faire du stand-up avec ça
ouais je pense qu'il y a un avenir là
c'est pas un petit poussin non ça
pourrait mais non c'est un citron pressé
merci
pour ce rire c'est important c'est moi
qui l'ai découpé à la main bam
on a eu quelques clients avant attendez
j'ai un scotch
[Rires]
Macron a retiré la réforme là on l'a
appris ce matin c'est le poisson d'avril
en avance ou c'est très fort Monsieur
Thomas Pesquet qui est arrivé sur la
lune hier soir il a fait ses premiers
pas sur la Lune et qu'est-ce qu'elle dit
sa femme parce que quand on est dans la
lune on n'est pas loin de sa femme
[Rires]
il me reste trois poissons
et là c'est bien là voilà
alors quoi de beau
[Musique]